Bonjour à tous aujourd'hui on va parler du chaos
alors quand on entend ce mot dans le langage courant le chaos se signifie en gros que c'est le bordel
mais en mathématiques ce terme à un sens plus spécifique qui fait notamment référence à cet effet devenu une expression courante
l'effet papillon
La théorie du chaos fait partie de cette branche des mathématiques qu'on appelle l'étude des systèmes dynamiques
alors petit point de vocabulaire un système dynamique ça désigne en gros un truc qui évolue dans le temps
on a plein de systèmes dynamiques en physique qu'il s'agisse du mouvement des planètes de la trajectoire des boulets de canon
bien des oscillations d'un pendule mais on en a aussi en chimie quand on suit le déroulement des réactions en biologie avec l'évolution des populations
en électronique en économie et c'est ce que les mathématiciens aime bien faire pour étudier un système dynamique c'est d'en prendre une version un peu
idéalisée décrite à partir d'une équation
d'évolution prenons l'exemple du pendule
il existe une équation je vais pas vous l'a détaillé qui permet de calculer la trajectoire d'un pendule et d'en faire une simulation
ça se fait très bien avec un ordinateur on se fixe un point de départ
ici un angle un disons 80 degrés et on regarde comment le pendule évolué à partir de là en appliquant les poissons d'évolution
Dans les systèmes de ce type ce qui est important c'est qu'ils sont
déterministe il n'y a pas de hasard qui interviennent et on peut simuler leur évolution sans aucune ambiguïté
si je relance le calcul de la trajectoire du pendule eh bien je vais obtenir exactement le même résultat
l'autre caractéristique importante c'est que même si on ne connaît pas super précisément la position de départ bah c'est pas bien grave
si je lance le pendule avec un angle de 90 degrés au lieu de 80 mais ça va pas
dramatiquement changé le résultat comme vous pouvez le voir
pareil avec la trajectoire d'un boulet de canon ainsi je fais deux simulations
en variant les angles initial de 1 degré eh ben les deux vont pas tomber hyper loin l'un de l'autre
dans la science telle qu'elle se pratique depuis newton
il ya cette idée que bien sûr les mêmes causes provoquent les mêmes effets ça c'est le déterminisme
mais aussi que des causes similaires vont provoquer des effets similaires
et du coup si on se trompe un tout petit peu au départ ça a des conséquences
qui sont limitées et quelque part c'est un peu la base de la méthode scientifique dans une expérience
on n'arrive jamais à tout décrire de façon parfaite
mais on sait qu'on peut négliger tout un tas de petits trucs sans que ça change fondamentalement le résultat final
et pourtant les vous connaissez peut-être des situations de cette idée marche assez mal te dérange ou au billard
si vous essayez de faire disons plus de trois ou quatre bandes
vous savez peut-être que le moindre changement sur l'angle initiale peut vous amener dans un coin complètement différent de ce que vous aviez prévu
il existe un système physique qui représente bien cette idée c'est le double pendu le
double pendule c'est simplement un pendule au bout d'un pendule
si vous voulez en voir un je vous renvoie la vidéo de docteur norman sur le sujet
moi j'en ai pas alors je vais juste en faire une simulation
les équations qui décrivent l'évolution d'un double pendules sont un peu plus compliquées que celles d'un pendule simple
mais avec un ordinateur - y'a pas de problème et regardez le genre de trajectoire qu'on obtient
L'évolution du double pendule n'est pas du tout régulière elle est plutôt erratique et semble franchement imprédictible c'est très différent du pendule simple
Et surtout regardons ce qui se passe avec deux doubles pendule lancé avec juste une minuscule différence sur l'état initial
ici il ya un écart de seulement 1 degrés entre la position initiale du pendule bleus et seul du pendule orange
et c'est parti vous voyez qu'au début les deux mouvements sont similaires
mais quand quelques secondes ils se séparent et deviennent complètement différent contrairement un pendule simple l'évolution d'un double pendule est
extrêmement dépendante de sa condition initiale les valeurs exactes des angles et c'est cette sensibilité aux conditions initiales
qui fait qu'un double pendule est un système chaotique et donc
imprévisible si on avait un vrai double pendule et qu'on voulait calculé à l'avant son évolution en faisant une simulation
il faudrait mesurer son point de départ avec une précision fabuleuse puisque la moindre variation changerait complètement le résultat
ce phénomène de petites variations au départ ayant des conséquences importantes à terme c'est ce qu'on appelle aujourd'hui l'effet papillon
L'histoire de l'effet papillon ne nous vient pas du double pendule mais de la météo
la météo c'est aussi un système dynamique un truc qui évolue dans le temps est assez agaçant au premier abord
puisque comme chacun sait on n'arrive pas à prédire correctement le temps qu'il va faire avec plus de quelques jours d'avancé
c'est quand même assez frustrant surtout quand on compare ça avec d'autres phénomènes naturels
comme les marais qu'on prédit sans problème pour toute l'année ou encore les éclipses qu'on sait prédire à la minute près plusieurs siècles en avance
on pourrait penser que c'est parce que pour la météo il ya trop de choses à prendre en compte
la température la pression la vitesse du vent et ça en chaque point de l'atmosphère terrestre
ça peut faire potentiellement des millions de paramètres à considérer
pour mieux comprendre ce à un météorologue américain edward lawrence avait décidé de travailler avec un modèle ultra ultra simplifié de l'atmosphère
avec seulement trois paramètres 3 c'est vraiment pas beaucoup hein c'est comme si pour décrire l'état de toute l'atmosphère à un instant donné
on ne regardait que trois nombres par exemple la température la pression et la vitesse du vent mais juste en moyenne sur toute l'atmosphère
c'est comme si tout le bulletin météo de la terre tenait en seulement 3 nombre
alors en réalité dans le modèle proposé par lawrence c3 nombre n'était pas exactement la température la pression et la vitesse du vent
enfin pour schématiser on va faire comme si c'était le cas
pour faire sa lorraine ses parties de trois équations décrivant une version très simplifiée des mouvements de l'air dans l'atmosphère
ensuite lawrence a fait ce qu'on a fait avec le pendule
il a pris une situation de départ et il a simulé ce qui se passait avec un ordinateur
à l'époque c'était à la fin des années 60 son ordinateur était une bête de course appelée royal
mcbee lgp 30 un monstre disposant de 16 kg est cadencé à
00 00
12 giga hertz
le tout pour la modique somme de 50 mille dollars
des dollars de l'époque en plus mais ça a permis à lawrence de simuler ses équations et voilà le genre d'évolution qui l'a obtenu
vous voyez ici la variation dans le temps de ces trois variables
on remarque qu'elle oscille de façon plus ou moins coordonnées mais qu'elle change de temps en temps de façon apparemment assez erratique
sauf qu'un jour lawrence avait arrêté sa simulation
et il s'est dit plus tard qu'ils voudraient bien la reprendre pour la pousser un peu plus loin
il aurait pu la redémarrer complètement au début il a laissé évoluer plus longtemps
mais il se dit qu'ils pouvaient très bien la reprendre au milieu pour reprendre
mullah sion au milieu c'est simple on prend des points intermédiaires qu'on avait trouvé dans le calcul précédent par exemple ceux ci ont les rentrer
dans l'ordinateur comme nouveau point de départ et on refait tourner les équations
alors comme prévu les trajectoires ont commencé de façon identique
et puis à sa grande surprise elle se sont séparés de ce qu'il avait déjà obtenu pour évoluer de façon complètement différente
à lawrence a évidemment été étonné un il a cru que sa machine avait une pâle ou une défaillance
et puis il a trouvé l'explication
pour relancer sa simulation il avéré entrer dans l'ordinateur les nombres qui s'était affichée à l'écran de son calcul précédent
or ceci n'était donné qu'avec trois chiffres par exemple 5,16 alors que l'ordinateur lui dans sa mémoire en stocker 6 du genre
5,16 1963 et du coup lawrence croyère relancer sa simulation en partant du même point mais comme il se baser uniquement sur les trois chiffres
il avait recommencé en partant d'un point très légèrement différent de ce qu'il avait fait avant
et c'est pour ça que les deux courbes ont divergé le point initial n'était pas exactement le même
lawrence venait de découvrir que son système d'équations pourtant très très simple et est extrêmement sensible au choix du point de départ à la condition
initiale et que même en prenant deux points de départ très très proche les évolutions finissait par être différente
quand il a raconté sa découverte dans une conférence quelques années plus tard il a donné à son exposé un titre restée célèbre
est ce qu'un battement d'aile de papillon au brésil peut provoquer une tornade au texas
et c'est comme ça qu'est née l'expression l'effet papillon
il faut passer un peu de temps sur le sens réel de cet effet qui est souvent un peu dévoyé
ce que nous dit lawrence c'est que si vous voulez prévoir s'il y aura une tornade au texas
dans disons un mois en théorie vous pouvez mais en pratique ça veut dire qu'il vous faut connaître avec une précision extrême
l'état actuel de l'atmosphère terrestre
puisque la moindre petite différence initiale peut mener à une évolution différente un mois plus tard
si vous voulez que votre prédiction soit juste avec un mois d'avancé
il faut que vous preniez en compte tous les mouvements de l'air les plus infimes jusqu'à ce que provoquerait les ailes des papillons
et ainsi on peut très bien avoir une situation où avec un certain papillon brésil on a une tornade au texas un mois plus tard
mais si on l'enlève et bien la tornade disparaît alors malgré tout ça veut pas dire que ce papillon est la cause de la tornade
dans l'interprétation l'effet papillon il faut bien comprendre ce qu'on entend par le terme pour ok
ok avec le papillon tornade sans le papillon pas de tornades
mais ça se trouve en gardant le papillon mais en ajoutant une mouche ailleurs on aurait aussi
supprimer la tornade et en enlevant deux papillons belle serait revenu
ça n'est pas un papillon qui causent la tornade la tornade est la conséquence de l'ensemble des conditions initiales de l'atmosphère qui a évolué
et la sensibilité aux conditions initiales est telle que tous les minuscules détails comptent et vont en quelque sorte
conspiré pour donner la tornade au texas
c'est important de bien comprendre ça parce que le concept de l'effet papillon
a été beaucoup repris dans la culture populaire notamment dans le cinéma d'une façon un peu détourné
la conséquence pratique de l'effet papillon c'est que si vous vouliez prédire la météo qu'il fera dans un mois
il faudrait connaître l'état actuel de l'atmosphère avec une précision ahurissante
et comme évidemment ce n'est pas le cas on n'a pas des capteurs ultra précis en tous les points
l'atmosphère et bien il y a une limite fondamental à ce qu'on peut prédire dans le domaine de la météo
quoi qu'on fasse on pourra jamais faire mieux que disons deux semaines est d'ailleurs de façon ironique le simple fait de parler de la météo
créer des mouvements d'air qui auront un impact sur le temps qu'il va faire dans quelques semaines
et vous voyez que cet effet papillon n'est pas spécifique du fait que l'atmosphère est un système très riche à décrire
les équations de lawrence décrivent une atmosphère ultra simplifié à seulement trois paramètres en tout et elles sont déjà sujette à ce phénomène
alors on pourrait s'arrêter là mais on a à peine effleuré certaine beauté des systèmes chaotique
et pour les regarder de près on va considérer le plus simple d'entre tous encore beaucoup plus simple que les équations de laurens
Le système chaotique qu'on va voir maintenant est très simple pour deux raisons la première c'est qu'il n'ya qu'un paramètre à suivre
la deuxième c'est qu'il n'évolue pas de façon continue comme un double pendule ou la météo mais pas à pas
prenez un nombre x entre 0 et 1 ce sera notre point de départ
l'étape 0 et appliquer lui la transformation suivante
4 x x x 1 - x par exemple si je pars de x égal 0 37 j'arrive à 0,93
et recommencer appliquer la même transformation
vous tombez sur 0,25 et recommence et ainsi de suite
c'est très simple vous pouvez même le faire avec un tableur
si on trace le résultat obtenu sur une cinquantaine d'étape on obtient un comportement apparemment complètement erratiques
maintenant faisons le même calcul en partant non pas de 0.37 mais en ajoutant 1 millionième c'est-à-dire
0,3 cent soixante dix mille 001 et voici ce qu'on obtient
au début les deux courbes se superposent mais dès qu'on a atteint une quinzaine d'étapes elle se sépare et suivent des chemins complètement différent
pour un petit millionième d'écart au début ça veut dire que notre système a une énorme sensibilité au point de départ à la condition initiale
c'est un système chaotique soumis à l'effet papillon ce petit système chaotique hyper simple s'appelle la fonction logistique
et il est inspiré d'un modèle très élémentaire d'évolution de population tels qu'on pourra en avoir en biologie
mais ce qui est fascinant c'est que si on le modifie très légèrement et bien son comportement change
prenons la même transformation mais en remplaçant le 4 par 1 2 ça a l'air assez bénin comme changement
et pourtant regardez le comportement qu'on obtient j'ai pris quelques points de départ différent
et en quelques coups à peine on converge vers 0,5
c'est pas du tout chaotique 1 au contraire pour ce système 0.5 est ce qu'on appelle un attracteur
Si je change mon deux ans 1,6 on a toujours un attracteur mais dont la valeur est différente a à peu près 0,38
Et pour un coefficient de 2,8 la tracteurs et à 0,64 alors essayons maintenant avec un coefficient 3,1
Là c'est bizarre les combes finissent par osciller en permanence entre
0,76 0,56 on a un attracteur qui n'est plus un point mais plus points à tour de rôle
la tracteur est ce qu'on appelle une orbite périodiques un peu comme l'orbité d'une planète est une trajectoire qui se répète
là on a une oscillation périodiques entre deux valeurs avec un coefficient de 3,5 le système aussi le cette fois entre quatre valeurs
Et à 3,56 huit valeurs
bon à ce rythme là on va arrêter de faire ça à la main et on va programmer tout ça pour faire un graphique
voilà en abscisse on va mettre la valeur du paramètre de croissance le coefficient entre 1 et 4
et on va simuler le système avec tout un tas de valeur
et pour chacune on va tracer les points où les orbites vers lesquels ils se stabilisent
ici on a déjà trouvé quelques valeurs eh bien on va lancer des gros calculs pour toutes les autres et voilà le diagramme qu'on obtient
Entre 1 et 3 on converge toujours vers un attracteur qui est juste un point et dont la valeur est de plus en plus élevés
et puis à partir de trois on passe à des oscillations entre deux valeurs
le point où on a un changement de comportement s'appelle une bifurcation
et puis un peu plus loin ça sera divisé puis à nouveau et c'est
alors on pourrait croire que ce qu'on va voir après sont encore des divisions successives mais non en fait on peut montrer qu'à partir de
trois points 57 on a un vrai changement de nature et on entre dans un comportement complètement chaotique sans aucune orbite périodiques
c'est exactement ce comportement qu'on a vu initialement quand le paramètre valait 4
ce qui est bizarre c'est que quand on regarde le diagramme de près on voit des zones où le chaos
disparaît et on retombe sur des orbites périodiques 1 comme ici pour le paramètre autour de 3
83 où on a des oscillations entre trois valeurs
et si on zoome sur ces zones de calmes ces bandes blanches on retrouve des bifurcations à l'intérieur
et on voit qu'elle se reproduise avec le même motif de dédoublement
suivi à nouveau d'une petite zone chaotique puis d'une mini zone de calme et on peut zoomer à nouveau dessus injuste autour de 3
854 et retrouver des bifurcations et ainsi de suite
Le diagramme de bifurcation possède une structure dite fractale c'est à dire qui se répète au fur et à mesure consomme dessus
il faudrait probablement faire une vidéo entière sur les fractales ça viendra en attendant je vous renvoie à celle de la chaîne chou romanesco
vache qui rit et intégrale curviligne qui a fait un très chouette épisodes sur le sujet
et puis abonnez-vous à sa chaîne allait vraiment super bien
la notion de chaos et celle de fractal entre des rapports étroits même s'ils ne sont pas faciles à saisir
les fractales semble surgir à plusieurs endroits quand on considère les systèmes chaotique on l'a vu dans le diagramme de bifurcation précédent
mais on va voir que c'est également le cas avec le système de laurens
On l'a constaté quand il est dans un régime chaotique le système obtenu par la fonction logistique semble prendre des valeurs de façon aléatoire
est passé par tous les nombres possible entre 0 et 1
on peut se demander si c'est la même chose avec le système de lawrence
est ce que les trois paramètres passe par toutes les valeurs possibles eh ben pour le savoir on va tracer leur évolution en trois dimensions
si vous avez un graphique en 3d pour représenter la valeur des trois paramètres de lawrence
un point dans un diagramme représente si vous voulez l'état de l'atmosphère à un instant donné
avec sa température sa pression et sa vitesse du vent
et on va regarder la trajectoire qui suivent à partir d'un point de départ que vous avez ici
et voici ce qu'on obtient en appliquant les équations
l'évolution fait comme des tours autour d'un point puis de temps en temps elle s'en va faire des tours autour d'un autre point
alors se faire une rotation aux accents pour que vous y voyez clair
Et on voit que la trajectoire des signes comme une structure qui ressemble à deux ailes de papillon et oui encore une histoire de papillons
Bon mais on a dit que le système de lorraine c'est un système chaotique
alors pour le voir lançons l'évolution depuis un autre point de départ très voisin du point précédent
ici on a deux positions de départ une en bleu et une en orange et elles sont très très proches
d'ailleurs on les distingue pas et si on lance l'évolution ça se passe pas comme tout à l'heure
et puis vous voyez que finalement les deux évolutions se séparent
mais par contre les trajectoires s'accumulent sur la même figure de papillons
Et si je m'amuse à lancer l'évolution depuis plein de points différents éloignés les uns des autres
eh bien on obtient la même chose des trajectoires différentes mais qui s'accumulent tout sur la même figure
cette espèce de figure en ailes de papillon agit comme un attracteur qu'on appelle la tracteurs de lawrence
mais ça n'est pas un point unique ou une orbite périodiques comme on peut voir avec les systèmes simples
la tracteur à une troll de forme et les trajectoires semble de sauter de façon aléatoire d'une aile à l'autre
sans qu'on puisse deviner à l'avancé ce qui va se passer
Comme le modèle de lorraine c'est un modèle de météo très simplifiées on peut avoir envie d'interpréter ça en disant que l'une des ailes de
la tracteur correspond à du beau temps et l'autre à du mauvais temps alors c'est évidemment un petit peu plus compliqué que ça
par contre on connaît un système dont le comportement ressemble un peu à celui de lawrence c'est le champ magnétique terrestre
comme je le disais dans mon épisode sur la structure interne de la terre
ce champ est dû à des mouvements du métal liquide dans le noyau externe dont la physique et un peu analogue de celle de l'atmosphère
et les inversion du champ magnétique qui se produisent parfois à l'échelle géologique de façon apparemment aléatoire
correspondent à des changements brusques dans les mouvements du métal
et qui sont comparables à ce qui se passe quand la trajectoire du système de lawrence saute d'une composante à l'autre de la tracteur
mais il ya plus que ça avec 16 autres acteurs déjà à l'époque de son article fondateur
lawrence avait eu l'intuition qui devait avoir une structure particulière
mathématiquement sur un attracteur les trajectoires ne peuvent jamais se couper et donc lawrence avec compris qu'il ne pouvait pas s'agir d'une simple surface
il devait y avoir une sorte de millefeuille de surface empilées les unes sur les autres et qui se répéterait à l'infini
la tracteurs de lawrence possède en fait une structure fractale
un attracteur fractales c'est évidemment quelque chose de très différent des attracteurs comme les points fixes ou les orbites périodiques
depuis on a appelé ça hein attracteurs étranges
sauf que si cette un tracteur est vraiment fractales avec une structure en millefeuilles là on devrait pouvoir
observer cette structure engouement un peu comme on a fait avec le diagramme de bifurcation
alors en théorie oui mais en pratique c'est impossible à voir il faudrait bien trop zoomer
mais il existe un autre système beaucoup plus simple en mesure de révéler la structure fractale de son attracteurs étranges
la transformation de et non
La transformation de hénon a été inventé par l'astronome français michel et non et elle ressemble à la transformation
logistique c'est à dire avec une évolution
discontinuent pas à pas mais simplement avec une dimension plus on regarde un point
xy du plan et on le fait évoluer à chaque étape selon la transformation suivante
x devient un mois 1,4 x carré plus y est y devient
0,3 x très facile à simuler là aussi alors prenons un point de départ quelconque et calculons son évolution
Et voici ce qu'on obtient
Et si on prend un autre point de départ idem et un troisième et voilà
quel que soit le point de départ eh bien on voit qu un attracteur se dessine avec une forme un peu bizarre
alors est ce que c'est un attracteur normal ou un attracteurs étranges c'est-à-dire fractale
alors ici j'ai laissé la simulation tournée
suffisamment pour bien dessiné la tracteurs et on va zoomer sur ce qui semble être un regroupement de quelques lignes
et voilà ce qu'on observe les lignes se dédouble et on peut à nouveau zoom et
Est révélé que chaque ligne est faite de plusieurs lignes et ainsi de suite
La tracteurs de hénon qui avait l'air d'être une figure simple est en fait bien un intracteur étrange avec une structure fractale
pour la petite histoire je vous ai dit que pour le système de lawrence cette structure fractale était très compliquée à mettre en évidence
et ça a été mathématiquement démontré en 2002 par tucker
et deux ans plus tard en 2004 quelqu'un a enfin pu observer la structure fractale par des calculs
mais il lui a fallu les faire en conservant sans chiffres après la virgule
la notion d'un tracteur étrangers très importante car elle nous montre qu'un système chaotique
n'est pas un système qui fait n'importe quoi de façon apparemment aléatoire
son évolution est imprévisible
en pratique mais elle suit des régularités puisqu'elle convergent vers la tracteurs
on a vu qu'avec le système de lawrence on a bien un effet papillon
l'évolution d'une trajectoire dépens de façon extrêmement sensible du point de départ
mais deux trajectoires différentes vont quand même se balader autour du même un tracteur
une question qu'on peut se poser
c'est que si on s'amuse à interpréter une d elle comme le beau temps et l'autre comme le mauvais temps
est ce qu'on peut avoir deux points de départ très proches mais qui évolue l'un avec
majorité de beau temps et l'autre une majorité de mauvais temps et bien la réponse est non si on s'amusait à regarder les trajectoires
suffisamment longtemps on verrait que l'une et l'autre
passe autant de temps dans chacune des deux portions de la tracteurs et on peut même rendre plus fort ce résultat
si vous prenez n'importe quelle petite région de la tracteur si on laisse le système évolué suffisamment longtemps et bien n'importe quelle trajectoire
finira par y passer et avec la même fréquence que toutes les autres quel que soit le point de départ
En pratique si on reprend le cas de la météo
ça veut dire qu en variant
légèrement la condition de départ on peut avoir ou ne pas avoir une tornade un moment donné à un endroit donné
mais qu'à la fin les deux évolutions contiendront autant de tornades l'une que l'autre
donc deux choses importantes à retenir sur l'effet papillon
d'une part on l'a dit s'il ya une tornade ce n'est pas la faute de ce papillon en particulier
et d'autre part s'il n'avait pas battu des ailes en fait la tornade seraient quand même arriver mais simplement à un moment différent
c'est d'ailleurs déjà ce qu'avait anticipé lawrence dans sa fameuse conférence
il écrit avec les années les minuscules perturbations n'augmente ni ne diminue la fréquence des événements météo comme les tornades
le plus qu'elle puisse faire est de modifier l'ordre dans lequel ces événements se produisent
les systèmes chaotique de ce type sont imprévisibles dans les détails des évolutions mais si on regarde les choses
statistiquement sur le long terme eh bien ils sont au contraire relativement prévisible et insensible aux conditions de départ
dans cette vidéo pour l'instant on a surtout parlé du système de lawrence et de quelques transformations simple mais on sait maintenant que les évolutions
chaotique sont partout
en astronomie par exemple c'est à dire quelque chose que poincaré avait déjà notée à la fin du 19e siècle
et on peut considérer que c'est lui le premier qui a mis le doigt sur ces notions de chaos et d'effet papillon
dès qu'il y a trois corps ou plus en interaction gravitationnelle
on a un système chaotique autant dire que c'est évidemment le cas du système solaire
l'astronome français jacques laskar a pu calculer qu'au delà de quelques dizaines de millions d'années la trajectoire des planètes devient totalement
imprévisible et qu'il faudrait connaître leur position initiale à quelques mètres près pour voir le faire
l'incertitude est particulièrement grande pour les planètes interne que son mercure vénus la terre et mars
en simulant des milliers de destins envisageable
lascars a même montré que quelques pourcents des scénarios possibles sont instables et peuvent conduire à l'éjection de mercure de son orbite et
la collusion avec une autre planète
si on revient sur terre
certains billard sont aussi des systèmes chaotique alors pas le billard classique en fait un qui ne l'est pas à proprement parler
mais des milliards d'effort mehdi hyperbolique et de façon générale dès qu'on a des équations
d'évolution non linéaire où on multiplie une variable par une autre on peut avoir un système chaotique
c'est le cas en particulier en mécanique des fluides et c'est ce qui cause le phénomène de turbulence
mais aussi dans certains circuits électroniques des réactions chimiques ou même les rythme cardiaque
l'idée système chaotique est vraiment perturbante parce que les évolutions ont beau être parfaitement déterministe on sait que quoi qu'on fasse aussi
puissant que soient nos ordinateurs il existe un obstacle fondamental au fait de pouvoir les prédire et qu'on ne pourra jamais dépasser ça
la théorie du chaos fait partie avec la mécanique quantique et le théorème de gödel
de ces grandes découvertes du xxème siècle qui ont sérieusement plombé l'ambition des humains de pouvoir tout connaître par la science
merci d'avoir suivi la vidéo comme d'habitude laïque et partager abonnez-vous la cloche tout ça si vous voulez plus de détails
mathématiques j'en ai mis pas mal dans le billet de blog qui comme toujours
accompagne la vidéo
je vous recommande aussi la vidéo de dr nordmann qui a notamment invité les de la chaîne syrienne son rôle pour parler du double pendule
et enfin si nous les creuser vraiment il ya le film chaos
qui a été fait par des mathématiciens et dont je vous mets le lien en descriptions voilà merci à bientôt